a high-stakes battle over a classified
memo on the Russia investigation is
exploding into open conflict the top
Democrat on the House Intelligence
Committee accuses Republicans of
changing part of the text before sending
it to the White House for review the
memo reportedly alleges the bureau and
the Justice Department abused
surveillance powers when they were
looking at the Trump campaign Democratic
congressman Adam Schiff asked
Intelligence Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez to withdraw it claiming it was
secretly altered now this accusation
follows a warning from the FBI director
that the memo is inaccurate major
Garrett is at the White House with the
argument that Republicans call a bizarre
distraction major good morning good
morning Republicans are pushing back on
congressman shift's contention this memo
was at the last minute secretly altered
saying only quote minor edits were made
a democratic source disputes that saying
what actually happened is Republicans
watered down original accusations in the
memo alleging suspicious campaign 2016
surveillance thank you all very much
president Trump ignored questions about
whether he would release the classified
memo he was briefed on Wednesday
authored by House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez the memo alleges
improper use of surveillance by the FBI
and Justice Department specifically
secret eavesdropping of Carter page a
trump campaign foreign policy adviser
the FBI once the memo kept secret saying
we have grave concerns about material
omissions a fact that fundamentally
impact the memos accuracy my loyalty is
to the Constitution to the rule of law
and to the mission of the FBI and the
president's FBI director Christopher Rea
and Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen
Stein went to the White House Monday
night to appeal to chief of staff John
Kelly according to sources ray told the
White House the memo contains
inaccuracies and he's concerned that it
paints a slanted narrative earlier
Kelley told Fox News Radio the White
House would release it it'll be released
here pretty quick I think and Everett
the whole world can see it in a sign of
division between Nunez and the Justice
Department the chairman said it's no
surprise to see the FBI and DOJ issues
spurious objections to allowing the
American people to see
information related to surveillance
abuses at these agencies this is a
wholesale broadside against two of our
respected institutions Democrats charged
the memo is a thinly veiled attempt to
undercut Special Counsel Robert Muller's
Russia investigation
the president has until Friday to decide
whether to release the document Tuesday
night he suggested he would House
Republicans drafted this memo by
themselves altering the long-standing
bipartisan tradition of the Intelligence
Committee no one here or on Capitol Hill
will say if this White House
participated in any way in drafting of
the memo either way John it could be
released as early as today major thank
you